Hello everybody. Hope that you're good.
In today's video, I'm going to analyze
Solana and XRP for let's say over the
next few months. And in order to do that
then I have to first uh bring Bitcoin
again. Okay. So um quick recap of what I
was talking yesterday's video is that I
don't expect to see Bitcoin recovering a
straight line from here. Uh it could
happen and I would change my mind. I
mean validation idea would be if price
can get above the high time frame
resistance. So 100K because then 100K
would act as a psychological level of
support and then that's when Bitcoin
could start to go higher. Okay. But I
don't really see that very likely
scenario. I see more likely that this
move from the mid-range is a room for
liquidity to trap traders hit short
stop- losses and liquidations that we've
seen yesterday on on the liquidations on
chain data. That that's what has been
happening. they are hitting short
liquidations and there are some more
around 95 96k. So price could likely go
there. That could be a deviation above
the top of the of the range like it
happened in October 2019. Exactly the
same chart and then price could retrace
again on this move. And if you've
noticed here you have a daily week okay
around 83k is the 50% of the level. So
price could go there and then bounce
from there or could even sweep the lows
and then you know start to form that
recovery from there. I see that as a
more likely scenario at the moment. Um
that's what I'm going for now. Also you
have here the weekly 50 MA and 97K 98K.
So that's going to be also a resistance.
Let's just say that Bitcoin is right now
at a very strong resistance level. Well
area between 94,000 and 100K. Okay. So
um that being said now if we go to XRP
the first thing that I want to show you
is that it has been experiencing a very
strong pump this week. Okay, if you've
check over the last 7 days, it's been
pumping over 30%. Which is insane when
you have, you know, maybe Solana uh
pumping uh 11%, AVAX maybe 16%,
um Link 13 14%, and then you have XRP
pumping 30%. You also have Dodge pumping
28%. Shiva another 30%. Um, if you've
been here uh for a long time, you might
have noticed or you might have heard me
saying that historically and
statistically, this is quite a fun fact,
but it happens when XRP and Dodge they
pump a lot more than the rest of the
assets of the crypto assets. That means
that this could likely be a force move
that is going to get retrace. Usually
when you see Bitcoin pumping say six 7%
and then you have XRP pumping over 30%
while the rest of the alcoin market is
not giving you those big returns like
XRP or Dodge. It means that usually that
boom is going to get retraced. Okay,
that's what I'm thinking. Now if you've
noticed not everything is bad because
we're in a very tight range since
December of 2024. That's over a year
right now exactly. So one year of price
been you know testing resistance and
support more support than resistance
which is a good thing over the last
year. That means that it's very
difficult that XRP sees lower prices in
my opinion. is very difficult that it
breaks below this range especially
because I don't see Bitcoin having a
bare market um like the previous ones of
75% drops in the bare market right now
if we go very quickly back to Bitcoin
and I'm sorry I don't want to spend much
time on Bitcoin but if you've noticed
what has been happening here it's
already been dropping 35% and in my
opinion the lowest that I can see
Bitcoin going do would be below this
low. Okay, that would be a sweep of
these lows, recovery, and price going up
because it's exactly the same that we've
seen in Nvidia and in Google. Okay, you
can see in Nvidia that that's what
happened here. Exactly the same. All
right, sweep of the lows and price goes
up. And if you go back to Google, you're
going to see the same thing here. Okay,
price sweep these lows. There you go.
and then price goes up. So that's what
I'm seeing exactly the same in Bitcoin
as a worst case scenario if the bottom
is already not in. All right. So um that
is uh my view on Bitcoin at the moment
and that doesn't affect my XRP and my
Solana view because what I'm seeing here
is that it is difficult to see XRP
going into a bare market you know of
going back to let's say 70 or 80 cents.
I I I really don't see that happening.
That would be around should be around
90% um bare market. Well, let's say 80%.
You know, I don't really see that
happening in 2026,
right? Um, so what I see in XRP to
likely happen is that this pump gets
retrace
potentially back to the well, I would
say that it's going to go back to this
support of 190 or so and potentially
this could be one, two, three drops.
Okay, the market likes to behave in
freeze around 170 as max pain scenario
and then from here start to recover back
to the range highs. All right, but um be
cautious because I know that many people
are going to see XRP, you know, uh
pumping this heart and I want to start
to join very close to price maybe around
here. Um most likely it's going to break
through it. you can do it, but just make
sure to to be able to close the trade
very quickly if it goes against you.
Okay? And then you can consider to
reopen longs at least around these areas
over here. Okay? That's what I would do
uh with XRP. But yeah, I see XRP uh
going uh quite a lot higher than we've
seen over the next year. I do think that
the bull market is not over. I do see
again a similar chart as Nvidia or
Google. That's what I see at the moment
with Bitcoin. I don't see a 75% per
market. I see a recovery from either a
sweep of the lows of 80K or the most
scenario would be a sweep of the lows of
74K. I don't see any lower than that.
Um, so for XRP is what I've said. We're
in a very tight range for a year.
Careful this point that could get
retrace and then from here let's see
where Bitcoin is. Let's see if Bitcoin
pulls that move that we're talking about
and then the rest of the market along
with Bitcoin can start to have a proper
recovery. Now, if we go to Solana, we're
going to see a very similar case and is
that we are also been for a range, but
it's been even a longer range. It's been
for two years. Okay, two years of of
ranging insane Solana between 250 and
125. All right. So what essentially I
see here is that this I'm going to
remove this so it's a bit cleaner. What
I essentially see here is that it's very
difficult again that Solana breaks below
this range and has
80 90% bare market. I don't really see
you know some people might talk that
this could be a bad simul in high time
frame. I don't really see that
considering the context that we are
seeing at the moment. I think that this
is more likely to be a move up sideways
move, a consolidation sideways move
before the next leg up. That is what I
see more likely to happen considering
the broader macroeconomic context um the
Bitcoin chart at the moment. But that's
my opinion for you to criticize. So I
accept that many don't agree with me.
That's completely fine. It's only my
opinion. So with Solana what I'm seeing
is the same. Okay, very tight range.
Price shouldn't price is is normal that
price does these deviations. You can see
that it does a lot of deviations below
the below the range lows, but it
recovers it very quickly. So in the case
that Bitcoin drops again, we could see
why not we could see Solana printing
another deviation. It is possible. Okay,
I don't know if it's going to be held by
the by 125 range lows or if it will drop
slightly lower. Okay, but what I do see
is that eventually and this is what
matters. What I see eventually is that
it's going to break this resistance that
we are seeing right here and once it
does then it has you know a lot of areas
to recover. You can see a lot of
liquidity pools in this area. Liquidity
pools are um very big candlesticks that
well candle bodies really that
are kind of like um what is starting a
move into one direction and in that area
there is always liquidations in high
time frame. Okay. So you can see in here
in here in here this one is been
perfectly recovered but we see that
there are a few more to recover. So once
it clears
145, in my opinion, that is when Solana
could start to see some more upside. All
right. But again,
if Bitcoin pulls the move that I think
it might do, it's very likely, let me
remove this. It's very likely
that Solana hits the resistance, drops
back down, retrace part of this move or
most of it. Okay? And then from here
start again. Okay? That's what I see
that is more likely that happens. So,
and overall I'm bullish again as I said
into 2026. Also, if we go into the
Bitcoin dominance, I have a chart here
that has been playing out uh pretty
consistently with my last uh
projections. You can see here different
projections in different time frames.
But let's focus on this one deviation
above
this um area here that you can see that
it used to be a previous support that
now has become a resistance. So what I
was printing was a deviation above the
area then drop test it as resistance.
That's exactly what it happened
in this area here. You can see it. Okay.
And then drop lower. Okay. And in the
more midterm what I saw from here was
pretty much the same. Okay. Pump up to
hit the resistance is the weekly 50 MA.
You can see how the weekly 50 MA is
acting at resistance and then price
drop. Okay. Well, the index, the Bitcoin
dominance is not a price really. Um, so
yeah, I do think that 2026 have a lot to
uh still give in the crypto market. Uh
maybe unpopular opinion, but I I really
don't care. It's just my my personal
take. So, that's pretty much everything,
guys. Tell me if you like the video or
if you want me to chart any other
alcoin or or whatever you want me to
chart. So, thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon.